emily network showcase
here on emily network the clubhouse
edition
very special as we have the new york
yankees
visiting the tribe in cleveland if
you've ever wondered about or wanted to
watch a baseball game with some hall of
fame company we got you covered i'm
stephen nelson
john smoltz is in cooper's town cece
sabathia is headed to cooperstown and
carlos pena was on the ballot
to get to cooperstown we got tristan
mckenzie here making this
making the start i mean obviously we
know the indians you know that they can
develop pitching like no other so this
is another one that you know they got
coming up
down the pipeline and for them to be
good to win this division their fix is
gonna have to be good so we'll have to
see
big punchy all right we'll talk about it
when we come back stepping aside still
scoreless after a half frame
natalia all coming off a really good
start against the braves um you know
obviously the yankees need him to be
good
it was a void left by masahiro tanaka
yeah for sure i mean i i i thought for
sure uh you know massa would be back i
mean you know he's pitching big games
for the yankees for a long time but you
know obviously these guys are going to
step up and probably kill the boy
we never thought about wait a second he
he's got a
world in his head right now as well let
me tell you something we're never in
control
like you guys are always in control of
it it sounds crazy
it sounds crazy but we pictures we think
of ourselves you know some crazy stuff
yeah all right hey mckenzie's
average fastball just to tick above 91
but he's still getting it by the yankees
and keeping him off the board ximena's
nine for 42
two homers and four rbis
he could not hold up on the fastball
upstairs and ximena's down on strikes
second strikeout for tyonne just looks
like ty owen has a good
feel of what he's trying to do to
hitters
show you upstairs with a strike and your
whole life do you like the way the
game's going do you like the
old-fashioned game where your starters
were you know seven days seven or eight
innings
i would prefer they go longer there's
the two two
strike three fastball poured right
across so tyonne struck out the side
he now has four caves cece sabathia john
smoltz carlos pena myself steven nelson
we have a couple special guests lined up
get to more of your questions on the old
bird first
second pitch the ball game for the
yankees and
you know we always talk about third time
through the order for starters for
tristan mckenzie it's the second time
they i mean the average jumps up about
100 points
slugging as well i mean so let's see how
new york tries to string some at-bats
together
well he's done a pretty good job after
the first inning 28 pitches i think he
had
we're gonna get some more g over shella
revenge against cleveland here in sab
did it in the postseason is it always
harder for the hitters that like kind of
kick ooh
what i say what i say
i'm out i say you can walk out out of
the center you predicted that
that's a high fast ball i don't even
play though
[Applause]
got two i want to see that replay the
celebration will fill them
round and third or as those who know and
love
phil call him major league leader in
torso
it's really been fun to watch g.o do his
thing man like coming up and
obviously we had miggy and then you know
he gets hurt and then geo steps up hits
330
and the rest is kind of history this
guy's been taking off he's all star
level now
you go after a weakness of a hitter
that's a weakness of a pitcher
and it doesn't work you're going to hit
batters you're going to walk batters and
you're going to give up more home runs
those are the three things we talk about
all the time
oh didn't you
back to back home runs for the yankees
and it goes from nothing nothing to
3-0 and he missed locations
and that's to your point carlos like
okay he threw it
the one thing we know about pitching
against left-handers is most
left-handers have that down and
sweet spot yeah and you stay away you
try to stay away from matter of fact you
throw your slider in that spot to get to
the back foot
because then most of those guys will be
able to swing over the top if you look
at where this pitch was supposed to be
and look where it ended up that's right
into it
so that that's the nitro zone for a lot
of left-handed hitters
and after the new york yankees scored
three they come back with back-to-back
singles to open the inning
and rosario chops one through the hole
here comes hernandez around third he's
gonna score
jose ramirez goes to third and eddie
rosario
down 0-2 in the count delivers
an rbi single the indians are on the
board
there you go the indians have a run-in
runners on the corners
nobody out so we'll see it they could
parlay this into a big inning man would
that be welcome
i don't know this was my homeland of the
year guys
it ain't got enough
hey okay we're talking we're talking
about coming back after scoring some
runs
how important it for you guys to shut it
down and man look at this
no outs no you guys are vape ruth when
they run around the bases you know how
big
what's the guy's name and wild thing the
baseball movie
he reminds me of uh what was the other
guy too um
yeah that's right that's right he missed
that ball
wow you know getting an opportunity
oh such a good he's gonna find a way to
get the run in every time man
got the job done we got hedges running
like ricky henderson
we're on that subject i wanted to ask
cece and you should never ask a question
with two outs in a broadcast but i'm
going to do it anyways
if everybody in the yankees team
let's get next
[Laughter]
so innings is from reyes did the big
three run blast
oh we got him again again
oh that's a triple huh um you won't
come on hustle
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is that his first triple i mean he had
his first stolen base earlier in the
game
we are seeing the speed i'm seeing
everything here
i'm shocked how many hitters that luplow
that's trouble
they got to start playing him every day
huh yeah i mean he's
considered this ball game but he's you
know the things that i've noticed
in the games is like you hear that
little uh that uh nintendo sound after
this
run yes like those are the things that i
noticed like when i'm backing up home
and i'm hearing that
that's right that's a good one brock was
such a good hitter man
really good hitter that just happened to
hit homers
he that's a dagger that's a
two-out dagger from awesome edges i got
older with my knees and stuff when i was
younger i could get off the mat
but oh no he didn't know
yes he did wow he's so mad
[Applause]
what's that cat doing mr shoes
man that was unbelievable
i got nothing i got no did he catch it
[Applause]
[Music]
you get the battle to it in this ball
game
and clubhouse edition is over 7-3
cleveland wins this installment of the
cc series